I'm really surprised by how much I feel
it I didn't realize that this was like
such a I don't know who hurts deep in as
a child but he hates coffee he doesn't
drink it he can't stand it he even wrote
a BuzzFeed article on why not only
coffee is disgusting but the people who
enjoy coffee are bad themselves I was
personally offended I am sick of this
fake news and so we're gonna have to sit
down with Stephen and we're gonna get to
the bottom of this hi Stephen Sam how
are you Stephen do you know why you're
here today I wrote a post which I
thought was very reasonable it's called
coffee is actually terrible and people
who drink it are even worse and then you
don't have a refined palate you don't
need to bring my character and the
character of good honest hoppy drink
thrown into the equation people who
drink coffee are all crazy because every
morning they wake up and they like can't
interact with the world until they've
had a cup of coffee I want to challenge
you to understand what it's like to be a
coffee drinker do I want to drink coffee
no is it only fair before I criticize it
in such a public manner why you have to
drink coffee at least twice a day twice
a day what girl that is nothing new you
have to eat a coffee flavored snack in
between
coffee every tart oh my god the
Werther's my grandma rest her soul with
will be funding your escapades and you
need to try a new coffee beverage every
single day can I please do like just
like a small iced black coffee please
and it's horrible we just finished my
first coffee of the challenge it makes
me feel super jittery and like kind of
nervous and anxious at that said I'm
about to trick my second cup of coffee
I'm feeling horrible it's so
uncomfortable like honestly I'm really
surprised by how much I feel it I didn't
realize that this was like such a it's a
full-body experience and I honestly hate
it my hands are shaky I also have to
have a coffee flavored snack so I'm
gonna have one of these pop-tarts I hope
the whole point of drinking coffee was
that you could focus more on your work
but I'm finding it very hard to focus at
my work it's shocking to me that people
drink this stuff voluntarily okay
yesterday was pretty tough I would
almost compare it to like the first time
that you get drunk I had no idea
caffeine was gonna affect me like that
my first drink of day two is a Starbucks
double-shot espresso and I have to say I
actually like this one but today I had
my first one at like 9:00 a.m. eleven
thirty having my second and then I'll be
done with coffee and then I'm gonna have
the workers original oh yeah my grandma
is shaking her grave right now
have you noticed that it helps you poop
so far nothing weird about that but what
has happened is an endless flow of pee I
think the poop they might take a couple
days to kick in I feel like I'm getting
used to the coffee flavor but I think
that's different than saying I'm
starting to like the coffee flavor I
think if anything I'm just becoming
conditioned to how bad it is the
caffeine is still a big problem for me
like it makes me feel totally nuts oh I
found this coffee flavored yogurt let's
go
[Music]
all due respect to the coffee yogurt
industry this was aggressively awkward I
had my second cup of coffee at like 9:00
p.m. so about three hours ago and I am
totally awake right now
I had no business drinking a cup of
coffee at 9:00 p.m. but the challenge
says that after drink two a day and I'm
not gonna lie I forgot to drink the
second one and so at 9:00 p.m. I
remembered I went into my fridge and
pulled out one of those camp and now I'm
ready to hang screen I got about two
hours of sleep on that flight and now I
have a full workday ahead of me so I
have to say for the first time in this
whole coffee challenge I'm actually
legitimately looking forward to my cup
of coffee what's happening to me I've
had two cups of coffee I'm feeling great
I can barely tell that I only stopped
for two hours last night maybe I'm
actually a coffee drinker things are
going okay it's definitely getting
better I'm getting more used to the
coffee flavor I'm not gonna full-blown
say that I like the taste of coffee now
but I definitely understand it better
I've been totally shocked during this
challenge by how expensive coffee is I
knew it was like a few bucks but like
some of the nicer drinks that I'm
getting are like six or seven dollars my
coffee favorite snack of the day has
been coffee flavored peanut M&Ms am I
gonna say they're really good I'm about
to have my last coffee of my last day of
this stupid coffee challenge and I'm
gonna do my biggest challenge yet I have
literally no idea this thing works on
their truck I'm gonna figure I know that
this goes just in there okay so I have
the coffee grounds
in here and then I need to put the water
in here I think the water goes in this
plane wait wait if the water goes in
there just get the one that goes to the
filter look at me drinking coffee while
I'm making coffee I'm a monster
I'm glad I did this week I learned a lot
about coffee I maybe became more
empathetic to the coffee drinking
experience but it's not something I'm
gonna say I'm really proud of Stephen
for getting through this weekend night
not happen this week but one day Stephen
will retract his BuzzFeed article he
will join the army of coffee drinkers
and realized the error in his ways if
you all don't hold your breath
[Music]